Thanks the flat circle cart Esther
O'Neill EV stick explains that one of
the Honda family smallest members the
fit also called the Jazz has had a
facelift for 2018 now the front looks
more like the Civic in addition it
offers a new trim line called the
dynamic it adds a bit of pizzazz
and under the hood a little extra pep in
the form of a one and a half litre 96
kilowatt
Ivy Tech engines excellences cover you
and that was just what the market has
been waiting for a powerful version of
the subcompact at long last previously
this gasoline-powered four-cylinder was
only available in the sporty trim line
the new front wheel drive City cars 96
kilowatts move it from 0 to 100 km/h in
just eight point seven seconds and reach
a top speed of 190 Honda rates the fuel
consumption at 5.9 liters per 100
kilometers the power hits the road
through a six-speed manual transmission
with gear ratios set low
next Roni points out that a 96 kilowatts
can achieve 155 Newton meters of torque
at 4600 revs this unter bow charged
engine is quite snappy in the induction
phase some drivers might have to drop
their natural inhibitions to get the
relatively lightweight fit moving and
enjoy the rev happy sound and learn to
appreciate the low gear ratios of the
six-speed transmission with every shift
even gun next to the bantha fencing in
the dynamic body kit the Honda Fit can
look pretty cool especially with its
aggressively shaped front that takes
after the Honda Civic type-r features
like the lip spoiler the sharply defined
LED headlights and the red trim front
splitter beneath the distinctive grille
[Music]
the dynamic side rocket panels and black
16-inch alloy wheels complete the sporty
image
the Honda Fit dynamics rear adds to the
look of power with a diffuser and a roof
spoiler
[Music]
Rahmi notes that the honda fits interior
is known for its versatility
the magic seats can be folded down to
form a flat surface for the cargo space
with the seat bottom lowering all the
way to the floor and if you have to fit
large objects inside such as a table you
can fold the seat bottoms up completely
the same goes for both seats of course
which makes carrying loads that much
easier oh that's Elijah design on all my
fifa's the controls are easy to operate
and the infotainment system with a
7-inch color touch screen is standard in
the Honda Fit dynamic also standard in
the Honda Fit dynamic are various
drivers assists including a city active
brake system which at speeds up to 32
km/h automatically applies the brakes to
prevent accidents a forward collision
warning a lane keeping assist and
traffic sign recognition as well as
cruise control and a high beam assist
mommy knows the fit is a car based on
purely practical considerations but in
spite of the smart seating concept how
many buyers have been interested now the
one and a half liter Ivy Tech engine has
put more life into it the car is nimble
and affordable and deserves a test drive
especially for they free-revving set in
Germany the new Honda Fit dynamic list
for under 20 thousand euros
[Music]